wake up
if we were gonna make our first movie
and maybe the only movie we would ever
make we wanted to do something
surprising
and pretty bold and go for it
one version of this movie could be a
very serious drama or
violent thriller if you don't undercut
it with
existential dick jokes there was no
holding back at any moment of the script
it was all just like let's just do it
every scene
was something that i was excited about
shooting i had never read anything like
it i thought it was really
singular and special and it made me
laugh but it also really moved me
are they real it's a movie that has a
lot on its mind
but is also really light on its feet and
i was so attracted to that immediately
[Music]
i don't know what it is it could be life
it could be death
it might be a dream i might be imagining
you you might be imagining me
it could be purgatory or a glitch in the
simulation that we're both in
i don't know the scene in the car
before she crashes is such an
integral moment in the movie it was our
first opportunity
to set up the rules so we can't die no
the loop just starts over there might be
some way to kill yourself but i haven't
figured it out and i've done
a lot of suicides so many it's a lot of
debate about how long
niles and sarah have been stuck there at
any given time
with niles it almost doesn't matter at a
certain point he gave up
and has been drifting for you know if it
was
50 years of doing nothing in the same
thing every day of just floating and
drinking beer or if it was
a thousand nothing internally and
emotionally and spiritually has changed
for him he's just broken and drifting
the only way to really live
in this is to embrace the fact that
nothing matters
well then what's the point of living
well we kind of have no choice but to
live
so i think your best bet is just to
learn how to
suffer existence the time loop
uh is a very fun thing to play with as a
filmmaker because
you know you could look at this movie as
a series of vignettes
and short films almost um that assume
different styles and whatnot but
for us it was really about uh sticking
two people together and getting past
the uh the metaphysics or or the logic
of a time loop
and just you know getting out to the
desert and and really um
exploring these characters it was it was
licensed to um
suspend disbelief they had nowhere to go
um because they're stuck with each other
for eternity and really just dig deep
into into the messiness
of these people i wanted to make sure
that if you were to go
back and watch the movie knowing what
you know about sarah that you would be
able to see in certain scenes
why she's reacting the way she is
because of what she doesn't want to
repeat
and the car crash scene is a very good
example of this no i'm gonna
get out of this
[Music]
suit yourself
what are you doing bracing for a quick
death i mean we can't die
but pain is very real there's nothing
worse than slowly dying in the icu there
was something sort of inherently funny
baked into the character of niles where
he was sort of
the audience being like yeah yeah let's
get to the part where we have fun and
hang out
it made for a really great dynamic i
thought between the two characters where
she's like
very understandably flipping out he's
kind of bored
you could just skip this whole phase go
get a beer
you know we're not whatever
see you tomorrow wake up
now you have niles who has been on this
journey
with sarah and now sarah's gone and
that shouldn't matter at all to him but
it does therefore he goes out to irvine
to
feel something he wants to suffer in
this existence with somebody
and if that has to be the guy that's
been torturing him for the past however
many years so be it
turning myself in torture me i don't
care
mother [ __ ] you're right it's dark
down here
what the [ __ ] are you doing here that
scene in the backyard of irvine
you kind of you can understand what
movie you're in when you watch that it
has
everything i love from some comedy some
heartfelt
emotion two great performances and just
a wacky wacky moment out of left field
you cannot be here who was that man [ __ ]
oh hey hun this is
niles niles who uh he's an old friend
tuna will be ready soon
and uh we'll be out back when nyle shows
up
roy's already now surpassed niles on
that personal journey
roy has found the beauty in the mundane
uh he's found the beauty in this routine
of his life which niles is failing to
accept in himself so this is your life
not bad huh beautiful wife
beautiful kids
little joey is wandering dog [ __ ]
it's weird but
it's beautiful what happened to marriage
being a bottomless pit of sorrow
things change you know
priorities change
okay so what are you doing here let's
get on with it you're freaking my wife
out
all right hadn't seen you in a while
yeah no [ __ ]
i ended up in the hospital last time i
saw you nurses wouldn't let me sleep
they were afraid i'd go into a coma
nothing worse than dying slowly in the
icu
i had a lot of anger towards you man
i mean i'm not gonna see my kids grow up
never going to walk a little livvy down
the aisle
i guess i had my head up my own ass i
mean i didn't really
comprehend what i was putting you
through
a little stint in the hospital really
opened my eyes though
one of the things that i think everyone
who worked on it was drawn to
was the comedy goes real big and real
hard but it also doesn't shy away from
some of the more philosophical and
emotional
conversations and moments
you know one of the biggest and
certainly one of my personal favorites
is this scene
between niles and roy where roy sort of
talks about you know coming to peace
with his situation and
it obviously all works as a metaphor for
what we're all going through and
you know what to do with the time that
we're given in this life and
at a certain point you got to stop
swimming upstream and just appreciate
what you have
and really relish it and no one could
have pulled it off quite like jk
you got to find your irvine
i don't have an irvine we all have an
irvine
hey who was that loony [ __ ] who
blindsided me with the cop car anyway
don't call her that
you took her to the cave didn't you did
you learn nothing from all this
she followed me in
well at least you have each other
nothing worse than going through this
[ __ ] alone
my favorite performance in the movie is
that moment where
roy essentially breaks up with niles i
think it's best if we
don't see each other anymore and we hold
on him and you see every single
point on the emotional spectrum just
wash over andy's face from
frustration to despair to disbelief
um and then he goes
and goes and shoots them you know in the
trash can
would you kill me one more time
just you know beat the traffic
all right side yard
i hope you find it man yeah
one thing i really feel like we had
going for us on palm springs was we all
saw what they were going for what andy
and max were going for
from day one and there was a it's a very
specific tone
and if it strayed from what they were
going for or got pushed too far
in any one direction trying to be
something it wasn't the wheels were
going to come off of it
and everyone really worked their asses
off to
keep it totally what it wanted to be
and i think because of that it ended up
being something really unique
the making of this movie was very
intense in terms of like time
we were only ever given like two takes
because two takes is
like an enormous amount of pressure
and like we did it in a weird way
it has become you know the movie of the
pandemic
which i i will always have great
affection
for as i you know cringe at what we're
all going through
palm springs is the movie that
we were after the entire time
you